[Musik]
im phoenix tagesgespräch ist uns nun
zugeschaltet aus nürnberg siegfried
russwurm der neue präsident des
bundesverbandes der deutschen industrie
heraus wurm 5 prozent ist die wirtschaft
geschrumpft ist das für sie nur gute
nachricht weil nicht so viel wie gedacht
oder eine schlechte und morgen ja in der
tat ist ist er eine gute nachricht denn
die fünf prozent die sind kompensierbar
wir sehen seit einigen wochen eine
leichte erholung wesentlich getragen vom
export aber weil unsere produzierende
industrie sehr exportorientiert ist hat
das schon erste auswirkungen nur diese
erholung ist natürlich verdient darf
jetzt die strippen
wann rechnen sie denn zum rückkehr zum
normalzustand sag ich mal auch von der
wirtschaftsleistung her ja alle unsere
mitgliedsverbände zusammengenommen alle
prognosen gehen wir davon aus dass wir
in 20 21 dreieinhalb prozent
wirtschaftswachstum schaffen könnten das
würde dann reißen wenn man gleichmäßig
weiter rechnet dass wir mitte 22 wieder
in einem vorkrisenniveaus das gilt
allerdings nur wenn einige ganz
wesentliche annahmen halten zb dass die
logistik entstehen dass der transport
auch über die größten funktioniert und
dass die produzierenden betriebe weiter
arbeiten können wie zufrieden sind sie
denn mit dem mit dem pandemie management
der politik bisher was ich
vorausschicken ich habe allergrößten
respekt vor allen politischen
entscheidern die in dieser situation
verantwortung übernehmen
ja wir brauchen eine mittelfrist
strategie die verlässlich und
berechenbar ist aber gleichzeitig
fordern wir natürlich schnelle
reaktionen und das klingt auf den ersten
blick wenig quadratur des kreises aber
wir müssen trotzdem hinzu
evidenzbasierten maßnahmen kommen symbol
handlungen helfen nicht deswegen unser
petitum
lassen sie uns gemeinsam mittelfrist
maßnahmenpläne aufstellen und die dann
je nach lokaler waage je nach events in
eingriff bin was sind denn für sie
symbol sowohl maßnahmen
ich stehe absolut dazu und wir haben es
in den letzten tagen mehrfach gemacht
alle betriebe dazu aufzufordern home
office maximal zu müssen nur die
entscheidung darüber welche kategorie
von arbeitsplätzen aus dem homeoffice
dauerhaft gehen welche vielleicht auch
als notfall was machen wir mal im augen
offen stehen und welche gar nicht gehen
das muss von den betriebsparteien vor
ort passieren dass können niemand quer
über die gesamte industrie über 100.000
betriebe und 8 millionen beschäftigte an
einer stelle entscheiden
aber er muss wollen wir müssen
konstatieren dass weniger leute im home
office sind als im ersten block da und
das heißt es geht noch mehr sie haben
offensichtlich nicht das maximum
ausgeschöpft
auch bei dem teil muss man hinter die
kulissen schaut im april im mai machen
wir es eine unmittelbare reaktion auf
neue erkenntnisse einer nicht
vorbereiteten industrie ganz viele leute
würden einfach nach hause geschickt
seitdem es in den betrieben im
mainstream investiert worden im
hygienemaßnahmen ja wir haben auch
arbeit in den betrieben wieder möglich
gemacht durch sehr konsequente hygiene
maßnahmen
deswegen wundert mich nicht dass es um
einen kleinen betrag weniger ist
prozentual trotzdem gilt auch mein
appell an alle arbeitgeber
schaut euch das amt zu konsequent inso
office wie irgend möglich sind sie da
auch schon weitergekommen werden zb ich
sag jetzt mal arbeiter am band geschützt
durch schnelltests es hat ja wieder ein
ausbruch in zum beispiel in der
fleischindustrie gegeben jetzt diese
tage also absolut stellt das sind
inzwischen gang und gäbe in vielen
betrieben da machen auch die
betriebsärzte liegen
wien stehen die organisation der
betriebsärztin ganz tollen job und ihr
fünf man kann sicherlich sagen ein
auskunfts geschehen also ein infizierter
kollege in einem betrieb da ist die
rückverfolgung zumindest sein
im betrieblichen umfeld wesentlich
leichter als wenn das gesundheitsamt im
privaten umfeld recherchieren muss auch
deswegen sind wir sehr zuversichtlich
dass wir das thema pandemie geschehen in
den betrieben vernünftig im griff jetzt
soll es ja einen noch größeren lockdown
geben was könnten sie als als
industrieverband ihre verbände ihre
arbeitgeber was könnte mandat dazu
beitragen
wir fordern alle unsere mitglieder
arbeitgeber auf das ganz konsequent
anzugehen
aber nochmal das schweißen aus dem raum
auf das hat noch niemand erfunden aber
auch entwicklungstätigkeiten lassen sich
nur sehr begrenzt alleine und im home
office tun wenn ich neue anlagen
entwickeln muss ich irgendwann mal auch
an die prototypen fühlt sich dann gibt
es eine grenze die wir nicht
überschreiten könnte bewusst wurden
heute wird oder beziehungsweise morgen
wird ein neuer cdu vorsitzender gewählt
auf diesem großen digitalen parteitag
wenn wir ihnen denn der liebste
vorsitzende imam überlasse ich sehr
gerne den delegierten der cdu aber sie
können sicher sein dass wir mit jedem
neuen vorsitzenden die gleiche
diskussion führen werden
eigentlich darüber wie wir dieses land
zukunftssicher machen auch und gerade
nach der pandemie wenn sie einen großen
wunsch hätten an den neuen vorsitzenden
es wird ja auf jeden fall ein mann
werden
was wäre der wie gesagt einzusteigen in
eine diskussion was wir zur
zukunftssicherung brauchen wir sind fest
davon überzeugt dass wir in deutschland
uns nicht aus der krise raus sparen
können
und übrigens auch nicht aus bestrafen
dadurch dass wir mehr geld einsammeln
sondern das der weg aus der krise
wachstum sein muss mehr investitionen
staatliche investitionen genauso wie
private und ich bin sehr sicher dass wir
mit allen parteien
genau diese diskussion im umfeld der
wahlen führen werden was muss passieren
damit deutschland aus der krise raus
wächst
siegfried russwurm war dass der
präsident des bundesverbandes der
deutschen industrie ganz herzlichen dank